تبعات الحرب الاوكرانيه تعود لتلقي
بظلالها على مختلف الدول الاوروبيه و يوما
بعد اخر تزداد الظلال قتامه موجه
الاضرابات انتشرت في عده دول بسبب ارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشه وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه قبل
ايام في بلجيكا وامس في اليونان اليوم
اغلق عمال مترو الانفاق نصف خطوط مترو
باريس في يوم اضراب عام واحتجاجات امتد
للمعلمين ولهيئات حكوميه اخرى الهدف
مطالبه الحكومه وارباب العمل بزياده
الرواتب لمواكبه التضخم الذي فجرته الحرب
في اوكرانيا سكان باريس كانوا مستعدين على
ما يبدو لهذا اليوم استخدموا الدراجات او
استقل الحافلات للوصول الى اعمالهم بينما
فضل بعضهم العمل عن بعد تستند الاضرابات
في فرنسا الى اجراءات نقابيه متعدده في
الاشهر الاخيره اثرت على سير الحياه
اليوميه في البلاد في الشهر الماضي تسبب
اضراب هل المصافي النفط في نقص الوقود
وحينها تدخلت الحكومه لاجبارهم على العوده
الى العمل بعد التوصل لاتفاق بشان الاجور
يطرح انتشار احتجاجات عماليه مشكله
للحكومات فالانتاج يتعطل في الوقت الذي
تصرف فيه الحكومه المليارات في محاوله
للتخفيف من تاثير ارتفاع الاسعار هذه
الدهوك مراسل العربيه كان هناك
محطات المترو في باريس مقفله خميس اسود
تشهده البلاد بسبب اضراب ينظمهم موظفوا
قطاع الناقل تسبب بشلل تام في وسائل النقل
خطان فقط من اصل خمسه عشر من خطوط المترو
الفارسيه يعملان بشكل طبيعي لانهما
اوتوماتيكيان ولا يحتاجان نساء اما الخطوط
المتبقيه فخمسه منها على الاقل توقفت بشكل
كامل فيما تعمل البقيه في ساعه فقط ويتزمن
وهذا الاضراب الذي يحمل مطالب زياده
الاجور وتحسين ظروف العمل مع تظاهرات دعى
اليها الاتحاد العام للعمل وقال ان نحو
200 نقطه تظاهر خارجت في عمومي انحاء
البلاد استجابه لهذه الدعوه
ليوم واحد لكن امكانيه تمديده وجعله اضراب
المفتوحا هو امر وارد لكنه ينتظر نتائج
المفاوضات مع الحكومه
العربيه باريس